octavia spencer has a day alabama get me
right now
just recently march march 21st
wow do you go back every year no i send
a card
[Music]
and obviously will and amy you're
working together in aladdin we'll talk
about that but um
octavia you have also worked with will i
don't know if you'll remember this
uh and and it was a session right yeah
there's a special moment yeah
on will's birthday i think either this
year or last year
i wrote about what you did for me i'm
probably gonna cry oh my gosh
we were working on seven pounds and i
was only on that movie for three days
will pulled in as i was coming out of my
trailer which was a honey wagon
i mean i was wider than the name and
i was coming out i was going to hair and
makeup the very next day
i go to my trailer and they said oh
you've been moved and i had been put
into like this triple banger which
you never get anything that's not in
your contract and the ad told me that
will had changed my dream
upgraded my trailer wow
he put you in a triple banger though
it's better ones than the triple backer
[Applause]
probably puts you in a the quadruple bag
no he did what he could i guess
[Applause]
look at you octavia spencer i mean
you're an award-winning producer
three nominations the win for the help
and i do want to mention
uh another movie of yours although again
oscar hidden figures
which got you to yeah
[Applause]
and that
that got you that night to the white
house and there's a picture
and i think it's safe to say octavia was
quite happy
to be at the white house yeah
[Applause]
like behave yourself you know this is
our first time in the white house
but hey listen they told us that the
president
wasn't going to come and janelle knew
and so she was actually across from me
and i didn't think anybody was watching
us and i'm like
isn't that a picture of barack obama
looking at barack obama yeah
in front of barack obama there's a lot
of barack obama
yeah in that yeah
[Music]